life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards
people demand freedom of speech as a
compensation for the freedom of thought
which they seldom use
anxiety
is the dizziness of freedom
people understand me so poorly that they
don't even understand my complaint about
them
not understanding me
life is not a problem to be solved
but a reality to be experienced
the most common form of despair
is not being who you are
the most painful state of being
is remembering the future
particularly the one you'll never have
what if everything in the world were a
misunderstanding
what if laughter
were really tears
knowledge is a wealth that cannot be
stolen
once you label me
you negate me
to dare to lose one's footing
momentarily
not to dare
is to lose oneself
the tyrant dies and his rule is over
the martyr dies
and his rule begins
face the facts of being what you are
for that is what changes what you are
many of us pursue pleasure with such
breathless haste
that we hurry past it
it is so hard to believe
because it is so hard to obey
boredom is the root of all evil
the despairing refusal to be oneself
it is impossible to exist without
passion
the self-assured believer
is a greater sinner in the eyes of god
than the troubled disbeliever
leap of faith
yes
but only after reflection
why bother remembering a past that
cannot be made into a present
on the secretly blushing cheek
it's reflected the glow of the heart
happiness is the greatest hiding place
for despair
it is very important in life to know
when your cue comes
my sorrow
is my castle
take away the paradox from the thinker
and you have a professor
a no
does not hide anything
but a yes
very easily becomes a deception
once you are born in this world
you're old enough to die
hope is a passion for the possible
[Music]
cultivate
the will
this is the armor that preserves the
mind
therefore do not deceive yourself
of all deceivers
fear most yourself
if you want to be loathsome to god
just run with the herd
my standpoint is armed neutrality
the only intelligent tactical response
to life's horror
is to laugh defiantly at it
to be lost in spiritlessness is the most
terrible thing of all
what is youth
a dream
what is love
the dream's content
don't forget to love yourself
whoever has learned to be anxious in the
right way
has learned the ultimate
it is better to get lost in the passion
than to lose the passion
i would rather be a swineherd
understood by the swine
than a poet misunderstood by men
life has its own hidden forces
which you can only discover by living
far from idleness being the root of all
evil
it is rather the only true good
people settle for a level of despair
they can tolerate
and call it happiness
sleeping is the height of genius
for it is not what happens to me that
makes me great
but it is what i do
faith is the highest passion in a man
you become what you understand
life has become a bitter drink to me
and yet it must be taken in drops
counted one
by one
be that self
that one is
faith begins precisely where thinking
leaves off
i opened my eyes and saw the real world
and i began to laugh
and i haven't stopped since
what distinguishes all love from lust is
the fact that it bears an impression of
eternity
the best response to criticism
is to smile and forget
the highest after all
is not to comprehend the highest
but to do it
if you don't have many friends
that means you have a lot of life
experience
nothing ventured
nothing gained
to be human is not a fact
but a task